foreign
[Music]
debut is something that can cause the
entire anime industry to Shake in a
single episode character introductions
can sometimes break or make characters
in anime so in this list we'll be
finding the best ones which aired from
20 20 onwards just for you from badass
teenagers to literal gods in anime we'll
be having a close look at a few of the
best and most up-to-date anime character
introduction
oh
after dark emichi was being beaten to a
pulp by guilla Masa Mikey arrives at
draken looking like the badasses they
are and suddenly kyomasa takes a knee to
the stomach everyone's silent and not
even dared to fight back making sure
that these two aren't just any ordinary
delinquents this scene shows just how
much Mikey and dracon are respected by
every member of thorman and their mere
presence brings respect and fear Mikey's
introduction made everyone clueless at
first but then displayed Mikey's
Authority ruthlessness and a weird habit
of giving weird nicknames gives viewers
a sense of excitement as a new
overpowered character joins in it's no
longer about normal middle schoolers
we're back with 13 year olds that will
make you cry
next we're here to talk about Odem
Odin was introduced in an interesting
manner a guy who foregoes modern norms
and follows his own way and that
personality is deeply highlighted in his
introduction a scene that truly
highlights this was that The Cremation
of his close friend were instead of
normally grieving instead object to eat
by using the cremating fire to cook his
food now others might find that
disrespectful but Odin is different as
he's a man of his own who only follows
his own path and to him that was his way
of grieving and his way of having one
last meal with his dear old friend but
we also got a glimpse of are his desires
and dreams of freedom from the isolated
island that he can't leave from a
wonderful episode that really showcased
his overall character and personality
and it magnificently hits its Mark in
those categories yes it might not be as
hype as the others but this debut surely
solidified his character for future
events to come
next up we have Pandora
this is the witch of vainglory who is
responsible for Emilia's whole backstory
and the incident surrounding the bond of
ice OVA granted she didn't come alone
but she just blows regulus out of the
water in terms of being overpowered and
we saw how strong regulus was in the
first episode of season two Pandora and
Goose never really had a chance even
after they pulled out all the stops to
protect the media they were light years
away from beating the Witch and there's
no shame in that though I mean have you
seen what Pandora can do how do you beat
being able to rewrite reality oh she can
also bring herself back to life too
manipulating senses and memories seems
to be the least broken amongst the
things in Arsenal and that's very
telling
let's move on to the hunting dog's
introduction
the scene started when a group of people
stormed a military Camp dropping
capsules from the sky a hunting dogs
were formally introduced to be the cream
of the crop of the nation's military
units this scene is expertly
choreographed with each member of the
group showcasing their unique skills and
fighting styles the animation is
top-notch with each movement and attack
conveyed with breathtaking detail the
introduction sets the stage for an
intense and thrilling storyline with the
hunting dog's points to become
formidable opponents for the series
protagonists overall it's an exciting
and gripping introduction that leaves a
lasting impression
foreign
next up on our list of character debuts
is millions knives from Trigun stampede
the scene starts with a beautiful and
mesmerizing piano piece unbeknownst to
us though that this was actually the
introduction of million knives in the
show a harrowing cloaked figure whose
role in the story was solidified the
moment he was shown on screen by simply
decapitating and slicing people up left
and right with no sign of remorse no
doubt A fitting villain that's the
complete opposite of Vash his Majestic
and soft voice contrasting his violent
and murderous nature was really captured
in this introduction an incredible show
of power which is befitting for a
villains such as him Millions knives a
name that he without a doubt certainly
earned
[Music]
now before we continue let me ask you a
question you're sick and tired of being
blocked from watching your favorite
anime shows well have no fear because
our sponsors expressvpn are here with
expressvpn you can change your location
to a country where the anime is
available no matter where you are in the
world I use it to watch my favorite
anime because my region doesn't support
a lot of the cool shows with such
thrilling fight scenes that we just went
over all I had to do was open up
expressvpn and select the United States
server and boom now I can watch Hunter
Hunter like dozens of other anime on
Netflix plus with their super fast
speeds you don't have to worry about
buffering or lagging you can watch your
anime shows in Crystal Clear HD but
that's not all expressvpn also encrypts
your internet connection which means
that nobody can spy on your online
activity so if you're using a public
Wi-Fi network to stream your anime you
can do it with peace of mind knowing
that your personal information is safe
and secure don't wait any further before
taking this amazing package that I'll
provide for you three months of
expressvpn for free that's right for
free all you have to do is visit the
link express vpn.com Vinnie tube or
click the link in the description box
below now back to the show next we have
gokushibo's introduction
a cousin we've witnessed the low Moon's
meeting which we may admit is a bit of
an anti-climax for the demons as they
were quickly obliterated by muzan
however as the swordsmith village Arc
now opens its doors to every weeb we get
to see the upper moons meeting the rest
of the upper moons were introduced in
this episode as well but none did it
better than the demon within demons
upper Moon one gokushibo gokushibo's
introduction was nothing short of
intense as he immediately puts a stop to
akaza and domar's banter the eerie music
the Face-Off between him and arkaza the
animation and even his eyes blend in so
well that you can't help but feel the
tension between the two upper moons
gokushiro's introduction cemented his
position and Authority as upper Moon one
even as one liner after akaza told him
he'll kill him it's perhaps one of the
coldest lines in Demon Slayer yet akaza
could do nothing but stand in
frustration as gokushibu shows the rest
of the upper moons and the viewers that
he is him
foreign
[Music]
ly the last of the dark Trio in anime
has been animated and by no one else
other than the master animators
themselves muffa
foreign
[Music]
's Paradise release comes one of the
coldest and most badass character
introductions in anime ever gonna be
maru's introduction was not only
building up one of the most devilish MC
poses but was certainly out of the
ordinary the scene starts off with Gabi
maru's execution as the narrator
explains each method from being burned
alive and even being pulled by actual
balls Gabi Maru survives all of them as
if nothing ever happened with a talk no
Jutsu from sagiri Gabi Maru finds the
world to live to survive and live a
normal life with his wife but as the
guards close in Gabi Maru shows sagitti
what true Ninjutsu is like kabimaru
burst into flames and as the fight draws
to a close he sits on a pile of corpses
and smoke the scene was an amazing
introduction for both Gabi Maru and the
entire series of Hell's Paradise giving
us fans a sneak peek of the Carnage in
action that was to come
foreign
every member of Tokyo special division 4
has their own distinct introduction
which follows a relatively cool debut
compared to other characters
however it is without a doubt that the
scene was a bit Eerie four more members
of Tokyo special division 4 were
unveiled with all four of them being
unique per se princey looks like an
innocent Maiden but is actually the
spider devil angel devil is a powerful
Devil with the ability to take lifespans
with a single touch violence fiend is so
strong even as a theme that he had to
wear a mask to make sure not to go
berserk and bean is well a shark the
unique characterizations of each member
of the team are highlighted in a
creative and memorable way each
character is introduced with a short but
powerful glimpse of their abilities
leaving the audience intrigued and
curious about their backgrounds and
motives this scene is one of the best
examples as to how to introduce
characters in a dynamic and out of the
box fashion
[Music]
foreign
was introduced in episode 8 where he
literally forced a dragon to go away
just by using a piercing Death Stare but
he got another introduction in episode
two and this scene made everyone fall in
love with the series
foreign
feel so much fear that they immediately
readied their weapons and with rudius's
one mistake all hell broke loose Ruger
heiress and rudius with all their Buffs
just managed to scratch allstead and at
the end of it all rujed and aerys were
unconscious and rudius well he became a
donor this scene just goes to show the
level at which of being called the
dragon God is in the world of mushoku
tensei from the animation to the
soundtrack to the stakes and emotions
everything that was thrown into this
scene blended into one big beautiful
piece all in all allstead's introduction
in this episode gave fans the action
they deserved and displayed just how
good mushoku tensei is compared to your
average isakai
my shine
as megumi is pushed into a corner by
asukuna possessed Yuji help arrives in
the form of a white haired goofy Sensei
known as satoru Gojo
the Gojo's not all smiles and Giggles as
he stretches his legs and proceeds to
demolish the king of curses just like he
was nothing every hit was impactful and
I know everyone was amazed when we saw
just how strong Gojo is the fight
choreography was amazing and the
atmosphere suited the fight it was a
perfect introduction for the world's
strongest sorcerer and an even more
perfect first episode for the series
this sets the stage with a larger story
of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen where our
protagonists must fight against
dangerous curses and ultimately kill
Yuji which was supposed to end the
series but we all know what happens in
the manga Gojo is loved by the young the
old dogs cats and even my goldfish this
scene has become an iconic moment for
fans of the anime and has helped to
establish Gojo as one of the most
popular characters in the series
in this list we can really notice the
number of Villas we have on our list
which goes on to show that sometimes bad
can be good and that's it for our best
anime character introductions from 2020
to 2023 let me know what you think in
the comment section below and I'll see
you in the next one